Hello everybody!
My name is Markiplier!
And welcome back to Subnautica.
Now we've got a lot of work to do
But don't you worry your pretty little head.
I won't show you nothin' that ain't worth seeing. ;)
Which is more likely to be this
AHH YEA YOU LIKE THAT *No Mark, my eyes are bleeding*
So, what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna get to gathering.
But soon, we're actually gonna have to go back to the Aurora.
Because somebody said, and this may be in the development mode.
But I'm not 100% sure.
But somebody by the name of
I DON'T HAVE THE LIST UP, OH GOD WHAT AM I DOING?!*running a youtube channel*
Somebody by the name of, ZiloFuse
Said, "There a room in the Aurora with a data terminal."
AND on this data terminal
Are blueprints to a rocket ship :0
Now If you may have been watching the most recent charity stream
I came across this connundrumnrois device..
Ah fuck...
Thanks Karen! I know, I'm DYING a lot!
It's just a fact of my life
and existence, so you could just let me be me.
Thank you very much.
Okay, I'm gonna go do that I guess..
Fucking Karen. Always (Kar)ing about me :3
That's why her name is that thing that it is.
Who the?
Who the fuck is ba-?
What the fuck is that? *ghost of hannah baker*
Okay something's trying to get in!
HEEEEEEYYYY!
What the fuck is that!?
What the fuc-
*Whisper* What the fuck is happening?
Barry!
What the shit is happening to you?*hes possessed*
Okay I think!
I think maybe Big Box Barry might be a little HAUNTED :0 *i told you so*
Cuz, what the fuck?
Okaayy. I'm gonna pretend like everything is perfectly normal here.
And that wasn't absolutely
Re-goddamn-diculous
So don't worry about that!
I'll worry about that!
And then I'm gonna go
And get more materials
Because I'm starting to fill up these things
I've got a boat-load of Titanium here
I've got another boat load here
I've got a WHOLE bunch there *and that makes a markiplier ship*
But It's not enough I tell ya
I'm gonna go get a whole lot hecking lot of them more
And then we got a lot of work to do
But I need to get to It quickly
Without delay
So I'm gonna do exactly that
*Wtf Mark*
*Amazing music by Mark himself*
I am shopping Titanium
And yooou Erin
*Lullaby by Mark*
Okay, we're full up there.
Okay
With this
*Marks mating call*
I'M MAKING SOMETHING!
Okay
And with this we have the ability to
Go up to a modification station
Wherever we need to go!
Which is good because
I don't know why..
I'm not 100% sure...
I forgot why I needed this >.<
I have completely and utterly forgot why I needed this!
Why did I build this goddamn thing in my goddamn base!?
*Beauty captured in a moment*
ALRIGHT!
Okay, welcome back!
Its spooky out there
*Hellish noises*
FUCKING- WHAT THE FUCK WAS THAAAT!? *darkiplier?*
*confusion*
What the fuck was that?
Fucking goddamnit okay.
Alright, that's how we're gonna be, huh?
That was exciting! Okay
But anyway I got more m-list to read, I guess, shit. *idfk*
Okay
So
So Tcurbittra says alright lets help Mark out
Here is a big list of important task before your final spelunky
you need to move your laboratories and get some melon plants
Which i'll get in the floating island later
and you need to gather Creep vine and coral samples
Which I think I can grow Creep vine inside my base(Big Box Barry)
Which I forgot about that
You need to relocate the modification an important machine to the cyclops
which I just did!
And then you must reinforce your diving gear.
which I might do, I like living dangerously
That's kinda like my-
That's kinda like my specialty right now
But right now I'm going to build something...
Amazing
Because I got some coppeerrr
Over here
And with this copper
I'm going to make
the most AMAZING structures
that you've ever seen
Oh, yes
Fuck!
Forgot
I need silicone
That's right
I'm an idiot. :l
Gotta go get silicon
AI: Caution, dehydration detected.
FUCK I'M OUT OF WATER
UUUUUUUUUUUUUUUGH
MY LIFE IS HELL
*thumping outside*
Fucking what is keep-
WHAT IS DOING THAT?
WHY KEEP SPOOKING ME?
I DON'T LIKE IT
*thump*
STOOOOOOOOOOOP IIIIIIIIIT!!!!!
*more thumping*
These are the ghosts of my dead children
*thumping in the background*
OF ALL BIG BOX BARRY UNFATHERED CHILDREN!!!
*thumping continues*
THEY'RE COMING TO GET ME!
Okay.
So just calm down
Everything is okay
There's some mysterious ghost problem happening inside my base,
but that's ok.
So I need to get Mister Fister back in base
Unless that is Mister fister banging up a storm out there
which he might be, because he is a little bit of a scaredy baby
BUT WE GOT OTHER PLACES TO GO!
So we're gonna get in here
We need some creepvine
And we need some other shit
I don't exactly know what that shit is,
but I'm gonna go get it
Actually, you know what I could do...
I bet
I BET
I BET!
*thump*
Oh fucking god dammit stop that
I bet
I've got my sea glide
*thump*
FFFFFF WHAT AM I HITTING?
WHAT AM I HITTING?
Anyway
I got my sea glide
back in my original base-
OOOoo
The Aurora has got a new decoration on the top of the tat
But anyway,
I've got my-
my sea glide
back in my original base
not my life pod- boat but the original base that I said goodbye to
and BOY that's gonna be an unconfortable reunion if I go back to that base
but-
You know
To each his own! I guess- I guess we can do that.
Why not?
So away we go!
I need to stop by creep vine forest first,
And then, I can go try to find my seaglide,
I don't know where it is!
I may have taken it down to my base in the deep depths,
But I need to go back there anyway,
Because I'm gonna get me some marble melon to be able to make some more potted plants in here so I'm not just chomping down lantern fruit over and over again.
And that way I can actually get some good nutrition in my body!
Before I die a horrible death down in the lava zone!
Then I can reinforce all my BULLSHIT!
Then I can make new batteries.
And then I'll be good.
But until then, I'm not good.
And I won't be good until I find this stuff that I do need.
So who's gonna get me
Some glowing lantern stuff?
Not lantern stuff, some creep vine clusters.
And then I need creep vine sample
Because I'm pretty sure silicone is actually made-
Or maybe the- No.. Maybe that's not silicon
But either way I need a lot of this bullshit here so I'm gonna go get that.
I'm gon dive in without any protection. ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Cuz that's how I roll.
Oh no, we're getting full up!
Alright here we go! *grunt of pleasure*
So scary.
Alright give give give give give.
Ah shit. Give give give, give give give give give give give
I'm FU-EFFIN FULL!
*strange animal screeching*
Don't do that to me! Jesus, that was a weird sound.
Okay, but anyway.
I made that, so hopefully
Ah, I put my god damn titanium away because I'm a god damn GOOF!
But if I get my titanium again...
I should be able to get what I need to get. And then build some of these *Planter pods*
And then maybe, just maybe...
*Dat face though*
What the?
Ingredients unknown?
What do you mean by that?
What!?
What did I make that out of?
WHAUH?
WHAA?
Did I just-Wha-Whahu?
I have no idea what the hell that ha-what?
Okay, whatever. You now what? I'm not gonna worry about that.
So I don't think
Ya, I don't think I can make It in that one but do think I can make it in the indoor-grow-bed
So If I put this... *Puts item*
YAAHUH
SKABLUSHKI
And then I put this
Ah noo :'(
I can't do that!
NOOO!
I thought I'd be able to..
Okay, so I can't do that.
That's fine.
That's fine, whatever.
I don't need it or anything.
So I cant make that, I'm pretty sure thats probably an exterior-grow-bed
That makes that thing
Which is kinda gooood
But I can't build that in here
Ya, that is isn't it?
Okay, but either I should be able to take these Creep Vine seeds down
Into the depths
And they should be able to plant some stuff
Right!?
That's the idea. Huh
Oh, and also I'm gonna make more lockers because
I can, because I actually do have a surplus of materials
And I actually am finding my self In need of more storage!
Because I do have all these different thingggs.
That are gonna be bogging me down
So I can make some more of these, and I can put more names on the lockers.
And hopefully down the road I can be able to do that again
Because this is like my favorite thing to be able to do this.
Got it.
Okay
So that'll do for now
So i'm gonna put new names on the lockers, first up was uh..
Zilofuuuse
For giving me the suggestion for getting the blueprints on the rocketship
Uh, then there was
*Translator died*
And then, okay that's there
So that's goooood
Uh, who said all the list of the improvements that I needed
And then there was!
CookieDarts
Who said to bring back BumbleButt
And I'm gonna do exactly that 100%
No way I'm not gonna do that
And then there's Gram_0911 *Sorry If I butchered the names*
Who said, build a fricken thermometer already.
If you won't do it in the beginning on the next video I don't know what I will do with you :0
Which sounds vaguely like a threat
And if theres anything that'll get me me put your name on a locker, It's a vaguely veiled threat.
Okay, so I need to make silicon rubber with this
I'm only going to be able to make 3 this far
But that's good enough
Because that's gonna be a good enough start
And then I'm going to be able to make
The Ion power cells
And then I'm going to be able to switch those out in terms of
Uh, my power cells up there
And that's gonna give me an unbelievable boost in terms of the power that i'm gonna create
So I need three of these, three of these
*unhuman noise* AANnnnNND that'll do
And when i have those.. I'll be able to make...
AH, ion power cells
HELL YEAH BABY, gimme dat power
I dunno how much power is gonna be -
*jumble of words* Okay
Little greedy on that, dont ya think...
A little greedy, but okay i'll do whatever you tell me to do
alright....and
ANOTHER ONE
hell yeah , gimme what I need
And then, Bloop.
Definitely good to put the power of a nuke inside a power cell
Inside of my only boat
That's gonna go down to a lava infused zone
And probably overheat and blow everything up!
Ah? Seems good!
BLAM
OH
OOHH
HOOOOOOHHH! *Yes Mark, yes*
That's a lot of power.
Holy shit
That doubled my power!
That FLIPPIN doubled my power  *Actually tripled it*
OH MY GOD
If I wanted to use every single other ion crystal
I have, I could make more of those.
OOO!
It's tempting!
It's REAAAL tempting
I just don't know. Should I?
Should I spend my last ions cells on them?
I mean I could go find, there are more alien caches out in the world.
And I could find them *Go find them, Mark*
That's not a bad idea.. That's not a bad idea..
I could go out and find them.
Okay, so here are every single location for the alien caches:
The Precursor Base, theres one in the Sparse Reef, which I think I visited.
There's one in the Blood Kelp Zone, which I don't think I've visited.
I've definitely visited the one in the Dunes.
There's one in the laboratory in the lost river, which I have
I have visited
Because that's the one by the big skeleton One in the Mushroom Forest
There's the teleporters
And one in the Koosh Zone.
And I don't think I've been to those
I may not have been to the
I may have been to the one in the Koosh Zone
But I'm pretty sure I've never been to the one In the Mushroom Forest
Because I've never even heard of that.
So I wonder what I'm closest to?
Lemme look up this
This isn't a cheating menu, this is just debug menu.
So I'm byyy
I'm at 250, -50, and -400.
So that means I'm 50 meters deep
And then my x and y are not very close to anything right now.
So, I'm gonna go to the Koosh Zone
Cuz that actually right near where I need to be
And also I need more of these Creep Vine samples
I'm definitely gonna need more of these Creep Vine seeds.
I sure to LOVE going out in the dark like this!
OOO BOY
AH, fun, great, yes lots of fun
Yeesh
UH
FUCK
Yeesh
He's out there
That's probably enough
I have enough power than I'm ever gonna need In my entire exsistance
And I've got enough Creep Vine to last me forever
With those Creep Vine seeds
Once I'm able to build my base down in the Lava Zone,
I'm gonna be able to fill it with Creep Vine
And get as much Creep Vine and Creep Vine seeds as I need
Which is good
Oh, hey buddy
Oh, I'm still at the ass end of you
I didn't even realize that!
I do need to make a still suit
That is another thing that I do need to make
If I make the still suit
Then that's gonna help me cuz then I'm going to be-
AHH FUUCK!
I'm beached!
Get off of there!
Oh
Hello?
Where am I?
Okay
I think I'm moving
So If I make a still suit then Im not gonna-
I'm not gonna worry about just as much water
I'm gonna be able to to drink my own PISS
Which is something that's always been an ambition of mine.
And then I'm gonna be able to do that!
And, uh, I don't know where I'm going with this but I'm gonna be able to do
I'm gonna be able to drink my own piss.
That's pretty much what I'm saying.
I'll see ya at my old  base
Ahhh
Hiiiii :3
Heeeyyy
How's It going?
Oh my GOD!
It's been so long!
Oh noo
Oh I thought I'd say 'Good-bye' to you forever.
OH KAREN OF THIS ONE!
You're still here!
Oh, you're so coooooooool!
I mean not really in all that stuff but, you know you're kind cooool!
Oh, so which one of you?
Had my goddamn SeaGlide?
Cuz I know!
I know I'm gonna need it eventually!
Hmm
You got a lot of bullshit here but not everything that I need..
Anybod- OOOOOOHHH!
It's my SeaGlide!
And all my dead batteries!
Which I don't need anymore cuz I have special amazo batteries.
But If I drop stuff off in here..
Cuz there's a whole bunch of bullshit here.
So If I just start dropping stuff off!
*MATTTTING TIME*
Let me get some Titanium back..
*Mating once again*
Okay, alright.
That's good for thaaaat.
AND
BLUP
And
Blup BLUP BLUP!
Okay
That's actually gonna be good for us!
So now I just go grab my SeaGlide.
I'm gonna pop this badass battery in this and It ain't NEVER Things that I need.
EEEVVVER gonna run out of
Things that I need.
First I'm gonna get everything else that I need..
HEEEY you got anything in here?
Jokes for days, Jokes for days had it, of course he did.
Okay, so that's good.
Got my SeaGlide.
With my oodles of power I can actually have my SeaGlide,
And wander around the ocean.
Without worrying about being caught with my pants down!
And then I can make the charge fins.
That are gonna be able to charge it as it goes along
This is gonna be AMAZING!
Do I even have charge fins?
I don't!
I don't have any sort of upgraded fins
Why didn't I do that?
I can get a wiring kit!
Oh, this is awesome!
Why didn't I do this sooner?
Oh, this is AMAZING!
So, I get the wiring kit,
I get the charge fins.
I'm gonna put this FRICKEN battery in my goddamn SeaGlide.
AND THEN
WOAH!
500!
FIVE HUUUNDREEEED!?
And then I'll never run out of power because I got a battery charger for this bad boy.
In my goddamn Cyclops.
FRICK YA
FUCK'ADOOCALY YA
Oh my god
Oh, and then I need fins. Okay so I take these off.
The fabricator draws from available data to provide environment-appropriate equipment
using locally available materials for your safety this setting cannot be overriden.
Oh
Thanks
Alrighty then.
BLOOP!
Oh, so these are swim charge fins so these
Will charge the equipment that I'm holding
As I swim
Now it won't charge it over the point were It uses it.
I don't think anyway.
But
What it will do
Is it will use
Oooh that's so good..
498 power.
I didn't even think I used it but apparently I drained a little bit of power there
Just cuz It was so goddamn excited about it.
So what I'm gonna do is, I'm gonna actually make one more spare.
Battery
Because I can.
And why not?
So, I'm gonna make another spare battery of the ion crystal variety.
And then I'm gonna need all the power I will ever need in my entire life.
And that is phenomenal.
That is PHENOMENAL!
The only problem is that It takes up a
Huuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuggggeeeeee
HUGE space in my inventory.
Which Is not good.
Oh also I-I think it's the- ya it was probably the flashlight that was doing it.
Okay
SO
This is going really well.
This is going really astonishing well.
I am really happy about this
SO, the last thing that I'm gonna do in this particular episode is
I'm going to find.
The Kush Zone.
Alien cache, and I believe that's gonna be right over this way.
Oooookay.
Whoo Hello.
Don't know what that was about.
But we are approaching the Kush Zone!
We are full of Kush baby!
If I remember the Koosh.
Wasn't the Kush like an extremely water filled thing?
Maybe I can plant some Kush of my own?
You think maybe I can plant some of this here Kush?
Maybe have me a good 'ol time down in the Lava Zone.
I'm gonna make a pit stop here and I'm gonna-
Oooh
Well theres the wreckage that-
OHH, FUCKING HELL!
HEY
WHAT THE FUCK WAS THAAAT!? *Me, Mark*
Stop fucking doing that!
What are ya doing!?
Get off my boat!
What the FUCK!
Man I- Oooh goddamnit stop it!
I don't wanna go out that door!
Excuse the voice crack *Excused* Oh god I'm brave.
I'm a brave boy and Im gonna go out there right after I save.
I got my,
Here we go!
What the fuck is hitting me?
WOAH, fuck
What is that?
What is happening?
What is hitting you?
Who's doing- OH fuck hi
Hello, again!
How you doing, friend?
Alright, Oh fuck.
I don't know what's hitting it.
Large organic mass, lemme scan this, I guess.
UHUHA
It's weird and Kushy.
Eugh
Fuck, hi, okay.
Hi, hello! Hi.
I don't know what the fuck is happening.
Kush bush!
Great!
Some sweet Kush bush!
Alright, so If I remember correctly this is edible.
And It gives a lot of water!
So maybe.
I know it's probably no gonna be 100% true.
But, ah fuck.
Hi, ah shit.
You're a scaaarryyy.
Scaaaryyy
I don't know what the fuck is happening.
But It ain't good.
It 100% ain't good!
So If I get,
I got some Titanium here.
So If I build another grow-bed
Maybe right, ugh I can do it there but that'd be weird.
What I got ano- what I got a message?
Who's giving me a message?
Is it the ghosts?
Is it- Is it the ghosts?
It's the ghosts isn't it, okay..
So that doesn't work..
So I can't grow it there.
That's okay.
Cuz with this Kush I'm pretty sure I should be able to put
This into like
And aquarium or another grow-bed so I'm gonna keep it
I'm gonna keep some of it, I'm gonna eat the rest of it.
Num NUM
Okay, I'm gonna keep that.
And that's gonna be good.
But who the fuck is sending me a message?
Because that- that's not supposed to happen.
That doesn't happen anymore.
I guess I could make another wiring kit and do that but I'm running out of Silver.
I'm gonna have to get more from the Dunes before I go back down.
You know what? Why not!
Lets fucking do this I gotta make a wiring kit!
Oh geesh, alright then.
Yee
Alright
Come out, who's there?
Somebody
Somebody wanna talk to me I guess?
This right on the- right by my, here we go this is a good place for it.
Line up that dot right there.
That's good, yeah.
That's good
High priority automated message from Aurora Life pod 13. Coordinates attached
Life pod contains the last known remains of passenger Emissary Jochi Khasar.
I said Jochi Khasar! Why do I have to record this anyway? Send immediate burial detail. Send immediate burial detail?
What?
Send immediate burial detail?
Wait, what?
Mongolian Emissary, whhaaaattt?
Why did I just get that?
Okay, he is FAR away!
Why is he so far away!?
I've never even heard of that life pod.
Okay, I'll get to that later.
That is a goddamn huge piece of crashed debris.
I don't think I've seen that anymore.
But either way I'm getting close to where I need to go.
I'm not gonna go there yet..
Or I'm not going to go see Emissary Jochi Khasar
But I've never seen this one, have I, no this isn't the same one that I've seen before.
There might be something on here that I could use.
I don't know what but there might be, so let me just
I'm gonna do my diligence and I'm gonna go into this one cuz I don't recall seeing one in the Kush Zone.
And I've got my Super-Scadoodle!
At least I'll go a little bit faster.
Yee
Alrighty then, If you wanna be all ominous about it that's fine too.
Can I scan any of you?
Ah fucking hi, oh Jesus!
Ah, this is a scary one.
Alright, let's open you!
Whoosh!
Okay, alrighty then.
Fuck.
Okaaayy.
I feel like there's nothing good in here, only death. :0
AH, I'm gonna leave.
Ah fuck this goddamn
UGGGGHH
I don't know If I wanna do this.
GOD THAT'S A LOT OF SCARY NOISES HAPPENING OUT THERE!
More than I'm used to, I don't like it!
Alright, whatever It's fine.
It's all good!
It's all good, fuck
What do we got?
Ah, PDA, good!
Okay, downloads the charter.
Alright, whatever.
I'll read that when I get out of this hellhole, goddamnit.
Fuck
Let's get, gimme gimme gimme, get me home!
GET ME HOME!
Get me home.
get me home
Oh boy.
OH BOY!
What the fuck was that!?
What the fuck?
Something just pushed me!
Was it a goddamn ghost!?
It was a goddamn ghost wasn't it!?
A ghost pushed me!
I don't like that!
I don't like that.
Okaaay.
Carrying ooon!
Ah, okay so.
This- this cache can currently be found in an incomplete state but there is no cache present yet.
It is in development here
SO
We got that, it's a little bit of a disappointment but can did some Kush here.
Which has a lot of water.
Which means that when we build our base.
If we're able to plant Kush.
We should be good.
And If we can eventually, down below if you remember
There was a teleporter down there
And uh.
Maybe.
Just maybe.
That's gonna be able to get us on to the surface a little easier.
Then we have before.
SO
That is all for this episode!
We've accomplished quite a bit, I got everything I needed
And we've been scared the hell out of the entire time we've been here!
And I don't know why!
Ghosts keeps haunting my goddamn boat!
Probably the ghosts of Larry.
Or Lester I guess.
Trying ta claw his why back from the afterlife.
But either way that's all the time I got!
So thank you everybody so much for watching
If you wanna get your name on a locker, or as someone has pointed out I can also
Put people names on....
FUCKING WHY!?
WHAT THE FUCK IS THAT ABOUT!?
Why would you just do that!?
GODDAMNIT!
Nameplates!
WHY!?
Anyway, so I guess I'm done here.
So thank you everybody so much for watching!
Hope you guys enjoyed this! Lemme now how I did in the comments down below!
I might pick your name for one of the lockers or a nameplate If I find that!
And uh.
As always, I will see YOU in the next video!
BYE BYE!
*Awesome Outro*
Subtitles by: Lewi